la poésie c'est quoi d'après jacques
prévert la poésie c'est ce qu'on rêve ce
qu'on imagine ce qu'on désire et ce qui
arrive souvent des passagers un peu
particulier des poètes de deux
compagnies théâtrales les profs
d'histoire et compte en bande dans les
bus saint quentinois ce jeudi pour
clamer prévert camus boris vian ils
prennent en otage les les voyageurs le
le conducteur aussi pour leur dire des
poèmes à leur manière alors des poèmes
qui ont été choisis principalement des
poètes du xxème siècle pour marquer le
18e printemps des poètes
mais voilà des poèmes de leur choix et
cette bande de comédiens et de
comédiennes voilà prends énormément de
plaisir apparemment à à oeuvrer comme ça
dans les bus de ski bus puisque
l'opération qu'on a monté avec ce qu'ils
eussent tous les ans on affiche des
poèmes dans les bus et cette année avec
jacques fournier les itinéraires
poétique de la casse qui on a souhaité
elle est un petit peu plus loin et on a
souhaité animer le réseau faire autre
chose si que tu transports c'est aussi
toujours un peu notre rôle de lien
social
onze lignes ont accueilli toute la
journée conteurs et conteuses un moyen
de sortir du train train quotidien du
métro-boulot-dodo laden le sourire dans
la joie de vivre
ce qui me plaît c'est l'ambiance dans
bus eux
bien que la choquera pas comme dj de la
joie de la réflexion du plaisir avant
d'aller travailler
prochain rendez vous avec la poésie le
marché de montigny le bretonneux
mercredi 16 mars